everybody
okay for people joining me recording in
progress we are about to do a review of
compiler functionality for future
versions of language
so i haven't seen this for quite a while
and all kinds of things have been
happening so
christopher do you want to
launch here
sure so i mean so there are a couple
different categories of
new things
so there's first there's there's
declarations which are things like uh
you know
before you compile the program you
declare a bunch of functions or you
declare some types or things like that
then there's there's some stuff about
how types themselves are represented
which you know often
show up inside of the declarations
and then there's stuff about you know
the functions that that live in the
actual compiled code itself
um you mean compilable code itself
compilable code yes
um
so i think the place to start is
declarations because you know these are
sort of prerequisites for the other
stuff
so the first um
some reason is everything is kind of
laggy right now i think it's because i'm
sharing but yeah so it's the first uh
function which is actually already in
system but is undocumented and its
behavior is now totally different is
this one type declaration which is kind
of the lower level function for
declaring a type
um
so honestly i think that the main uses
of this will be i mean first of all like
interfacing with external programs where
you know
there there are all sorts of exotic
types that you might need to interface
with and then also you know if you're
sort of
uh
yeah i mean this one i think is if
you're just trying to compile a quick
program what does this mean what does
this mean this is the word product here
in the sense of our system function
product or is it something it's like a
structure or a structure
a struct
but it's got an algebraic name
this was previously called sum now it's
union this one is still called product
but it could be struct or record or
several other women so these are
oh these are
the first argument is all the type of
thing you're declaring it's not so these
aren't these aren't four different
function names this is these are four
different
types of types you're declaring um why
don't why have we decided not to have a
thing called types product or struct or
something like that well we talked about
this but but i mean i think that the
basic there was i mean what we talked
about before is basically how you could
either have it so that there's a
separate symbol for each of these
different things and they're sort of uh
you know
with the purpose of being able to do
some sort of algebra with it and stuff
like that um but basically the
conclusion was that this is a little bit
you know the way this is set up you know
that kind of algebra that sort of
symbolic algebra doesn't really make
sense and so
better just to have them all in one
function
um do we expect that there might be i
mean because this is like
from c onward these are basically the
names
i mean at least uh
you know struct union whatever these are
basically type def these are basically
names that have i mean there aren't more
than this other i mean there's another
another 15 of these that are like mine
well there's a couple there's a couple
of other ones there's some more yeah
there are some are yeah so i mean for
example um
uh
right so i mean for example there are a
couple different ways you can do aliases
so actually there's already i'm not sure
this would be documented initially but
there's already one called macro so
basically this one is basically just you
anytime you see the name foo you replace
it with this which is basically what a c
type def does that's as opposed to an
alias
which is i think the more documentable
one which is basically saying i want to
actually new type but i want it to be
implement you know as its implementation
it will use integer 64 in this case
which is different because it means that
if you have a function that takes a foo
you know you can have a function that
either takes an integer or it takes a
foo it might have different behavior in
those two cases but if you have a macro
then it can't have different behavior
but this is probably the documentable
one what is that in any case
abstract is for declaring an abstract
type i mean this is basically a
otherwise known as a type class
basically this is like you'd have
something like numbers would be an
abstract type and that way you can have
a function where you say this takes any
number as opposed to saying it takes an
integer
um
richard here is asking about dependent
types
do we have anything to say about
dependent types
yes we we we we do have dependent types
that depend upon terms
um
yes we we do that's further down that's
the type literal
well but yeah i mean these this is a
more it's it's not
uh yeah i mean we'll see how that works
slower down it's not like the
full-fledged you call absolute value on
integer 64 and depending on what the
number is it's going to return different
types
um
so
or you know same with square root so
that's it doesn't quite do that it's a
bit simpler
okay but question up here so i mean this
is for building
types um this type declaration thing is
for building up types
from simpler types this is a type
constructor
constant yes
yes and and how many of these i mean
these types are going to get really
complicated really quickly i mean are
these things that users are going to see
or are they or are they always just
going to be
you know
if you're if you're compiling i i think
i think um
so first of all if you're just
com if you're not decl defining any of
your own
you know if you're basically just
compiling a bunch of
stuff that uses system functions then
you should never have to write any of
these
i think then if you're defining a little
bit of your own stuff then you're going
to end up using this thing which is the
higher level version
that basically does a lot of this type
declaration stuff automatically and in
kind of a cleaner way but is a bit more
restricted
and which also can't really create types
that interact with external programs
so
this is the one that people will
actually use i think okay so maybe type
declaration is maybe has some nice
pretty print form in case you see it
somewhere as something that you created
you know one time in antiquity it was
created and then people just used it
from then on out
that are fair
i'm not sure you mean by pretty print
form but i mean this is a low level
functions point all right okay fine i
think i understand what it does
okay it's like set sct doesn't have a
print form i mean well it has like coal
equals so i guess in that sense it does
but it doesn't have a nice box
representation
right
um i mean we do document some of these
there's a page of compile there's a
guide page of compiled types
where we document various types although
it needs to have a lot more types in it
yeah it's conservative in documenting
things that are really
concretely official yes
okay
polymorphic declarations
right i mean so basically this is just a
syntax thing for you know okay there's a
few pieces of syntax here but the main
piece is uh
but basically this is the case of if i
have a struct and you know
it contains
you know two fields that are the same
type but that could be any type or i
have a structure contains you know
one number and one list but it could be
any type of number right then this is
sort of the syntax for that
there's also i'm implicitly using this
this thing here which is equivalent to
this here and we've talked about this a
lot before lower down there's a proposal
about a special piece of syntax for kind
of
avoiding this
why is the product type up there why is
that not an association the the payload
of the product type it could be it could
be i i'm not sure whether it's better
for it to be an association or a list of
rules there's another place where this
kind of comes up and either way they
should be consistent
but um
i think it could be i think it could
accept an association i think that would
be totally because those are unique
field names they they are unique yes
correct yes yes
one reason why not is in principle
you can have these things without names
so we we don't really use that but in
principle that that's feasible
that's a good reason to not have then
you would just have t and real 64. yeah
right
but but can you have some with names and
some without names
i don't think so
because they'd either have to be
positional or they have to have a name
yes i mean
i feel like having an association where
some of these things don't have keys
yeah
i mean i i don't think that's so useful
right kind of the natural design thing
would be it's either a list in which
case it's positional or it's an
association in which case it's called
keys
yeah i think that would be that would
make some sense
okay so let's see this constrained
uh
like by the way i assume uh who who is
pm'ing here is it aubry is bming yes and
so yes and they you'll you'll um you're
taking notes on these various items yes
yes
okay good
all right so let me try to understand
this thing here the type declaration of
the with this t element of numbers
right so basically the point is is that
if you have a polymorphic type or or
sort of a parametrized type
um
then it means that type will take
various arguments and the syntax for
that is you either write you know
foo and then it takes some arguments you
know foo of integer 64. or maybe you
i'll use a concrete example packed array
of integer 64 and then it you know it
takes the the rank so it's you know a
rank it's a matrix of integer six boards
for example there's an alternative
syntax which
you know is is the shorthand which again
i think we'd like to escape using some
sort of maybe
special
syntax stuff that hasn't been
implemented yet which is like this but
but either way the point is is that
basically what what this is doing is
it's declaring
that we're going to have a type that's
you know foo of something and we're
going to have so maybe some constraints
like that something has to be a number
and then this is the set of fields that
we're going to have in that type
but so if if that thing was the integer
64 thing there
what would the
the let's say that was t
was the thing which is filled in
impactor ray's engine 64. what would the
element of things say there
the element you mean in other words
let's assume
okay once you write the type decoration
four-pack terrain sort of fool put back
together the
then this constraint doesn't you know it
would be something like uh you know
space packable i think actually
sure but
yeah i mean
some some abstract type that's that's
defined somewhere else
and then uh and then for your fields
would be something like you know what
about
dollar an integer so is there a list of
no r is not an integer r is a type
literal which we'll see later
i mean since the point is don't you have
to declare what what happens if you had
two types in the packed array
another integer four comma real 64. for
example yeah there's a t and a
right you wouldn't the program wouldn't
compile
why
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be specified
because basically the
there's no declaration of factory that
works with
just wouldn't find a type that matches
that
no i understand if it wasn't packed
array if it was some newly introduced
thing
which had two parameters both of which
could be types is that possible yes sure
then that third argument will be a list
t element of base packable u element of
something else yes yes correct correct
you're
right i right
you could have something depends whether
you want to put a constraint on it or
not but yeah i'd like to get a hash
table that goes from the type of the
keys to the type of the values
right so then you would say t1 goes to
whatever yeah
no
yeah i mean this is how you if you
wanted to have a pair yeah this is one
way you could do it something like that
i am utterly confused here why why is
there not a third argument like there
was above with the constraints
because in this case i'm not imposing a
constraint i could impose one but i'm in
in this case
here i'm just talking about a pair right
okay but fine but if you have any t1 or
any t2
let's say you did want that them to be
constrained i'm just trying to
understand this yes then there'll be a
third argument there which would be t1
elements of blah blah blah t2 elements
of blah blah blah correct correct
exactly yes exactly okay all right fine
and i think oh yeah you can either write
a list or you can write with and and
stuff but yeah
oh you can write it with hand
so this is the notion yeah that
that
type containment is represented by
element of is that that's that's a thing
and that's we're safely doing that is
that correct
i mean i mean
yeah i mean it's a little bit strange
because this is a string
right but i think that
if you know if we just accept that
element is just this is just some little
symbolic object and i think yeah that's
that that's perfectly safe so we're
imagining that element of like rule is
itself inert but upon being you know
because we can perfectly well have rules
with strings on the right-hand side
but so you're we're imagining that
element of is sort of the next
you know it's something like rule
so i think it's called element not
element of but yeah i mean i think
this is yes this is assuming that
element is just a totally inert thing
which i think it is i i think it is yes
it should be
right i mean it's it's it's primarily
done it is not inert but but if the if
the the domain is a string then it is
completely inert um when is it not a
note rob oh try something like this
um positive integers
sure
oh i see
it's interesting though that this
doesn't work i guess it's the domain
x instead of a one and you'll see what
it expands to as well it sometimes
expands
maybe if i say
some sort of function expand or i don't
even know
just just just replace the 1 and n sub 2
with an x and you'll see what happens
n sub two there the one that says one
element sub two ah
make it x oh the x yeah yeah right well
you'd
wait but you've got the
idea i see huh
that's a little scary
well i'm not i'm not a huge fan of this
but but you know that's the way roger
and adam have designed this stuff so
okay
hmm
i i have this feeling that we're going
to end up with something where
the algebra of of element is not going
to be a perfect fit for our
sort of uh computational types but we'll
see
okay
right i mean this in this i mean the way
that the abstract type system works i
mean there is some like
i mean it's like a dag
right so
or maybe even a no it's a dag right
isn't it so yeah
yeah so i mean i think that the like
algebra of how you know
being an element
of a set is also kind of a dagger or a
tree so i think that is kind of okay i
i'd be more worried just about the like
the literal like syntax of
is this going to evaluate yeah i know i
know that's why i'm saying element might
not be quite the right concept anyway
let's keep going we've got lots to go
through yeah okay fine i get this okay
so so the next um well actually i'm
gonna i'm gonna quickly rearrange these
so the next uh the next one is basically
um the higher level way of declaring
types
which has several syntaxes but the basic
the basic idea is
this one is like
i i want to create a type and i want to
have these fields and stuff like that
this one is there's some expression
there's some like common pattern of
expressions and i'd like to be able to
you know uh
create a type that sort of efficiently
represents that common pattern so for
example um
uh let me skip to this this example so
this would be for instance declares type
called undirected edge
which represents you know
a thing with head undirected edge where
both of its arguments are integers for
example right or um you know this
declares uh an undirected edge where you
know it takes a single argument and you
know it has two slots that are the same
type or something like that right
um and the point is that we're just
getting this i'm not completely getting
this so this is
what does this do is this like what this
does
what what it does is it says let's say
you know this is a common
let's say that you have a million uh you
have a million uh undirected edges
containing two integers right you can
imagine you know if you have a big graph
with integer vertices you might have you
know a billion of these right
and
in compiled code
you know one way of representing them is
just representing them using an
expression
yeah that's not very efficient for you
know both because it has to disassemble
the expression because the expression
isn't very you know you can pack it more
efficiently and so on so basically what
this does when you write compiled
expression declaration of undirected
edge comma this what it does it declares
a type product and it declares a whole
bunch of other functions that go along
with it
so that basically for the purposes of
your compiled code
you basically have an efficient struct
which represents this object but it
represents it as a struct not as an
expression
so in other words
when you compile it it will be turned
into this raw thing that you have
declared here when you pass it into or
out of it puts it into or takes it out
of
so it integrates
with the evaluation how does this relate
to our data container concept
it is very related because basically if
you can if you have a
a compiled you know struct
representation of a type it means that
that uh at least my understanding is it
means that basically you can put it into
the you know rob's prototype data
container stuff
can you speak to that
yes i think i think this this is
actually a huge possibility and that's
that's a phase of work i haven't done
yet but i'm looking into what sort of
types we could support you know with
with little compiled libraries or things
like this that
it would give us a lot more flexibility
then but so what you're doing with data
container right now is the destination
is packed arrays and things is that
right
yes the destination is cached arrays and
numerical rays but i think there's
actually so this would be a a way of
having a customized destination
right
cool
okay on which certain operations might
work and many would not because you'd
have to you know given the data
structure that you're going to use for
undirected edge you have to have a whole
you know flotilla of functions that work
around that
right but that's what this function here
does basically is that it defines you
know once
so if you just declare a type product
you know called foo
you know
now if i want to construct this food
type i have to use this lower level
function or if i want to extract this
field i have to use this lower level
function the point about compile
expression declaration is it declares
sort of all the functions that make it
look like you are actually using you
know like something in the top level so
for example if you want to construct it
in compiled code you just run undirected
edge and then give it some arguments and
it will construct one or
you know if you uh articulation
part extraction works um asking for the
head works asking for the length works
um
reverse
doesn't work and reverse can't work in
general it could work in some cases it
can't work in general because i'm not
sure it's a good idea i'm just trying to
understand there's a certain set of
of type poking functions that can work
right here's an example where you would
add functions so so i did this business
with around i don't know over a year ago
that gave us you know like a factor of
50 speed up
and it would have been much easier to do
with this system but i would have still
had to add some functions
to do the basic arithmetic for around
because that's sort of not something
that applies for every expression
but the the the coming in and out of
expressions would have been pretty much
automated by this yeah okay but the
thing i'm trying to understand is
usually we have things that are opaque
atomic objects
that can only be poked and peaked at in
very specific ways
this is something where you're saying
declare something as an expression which
normally would be manipulable at all
levels but what this will do is it will
declare it as an expression which allows
only a limited set of intrinsic
operations on it
yeah in compiled code outside of the
compiler you can do what you want it's
just a regular expression the regular
normal expression yes right i mean
there's a certain amount of floppiness
that's sure that that you can't you know
i mean there's crazy things you can do
with with expressions where you know you
you map all some crazy function over it
right now it applies to the head but
some other crazy expression and yeah
that can't be compiled so i mean these
are pseudo-atomic things
except that certain operations work just
as they do on typical you know on a
sparse array or some other atomic thing
and what we're saying is that the
compiled expression declaration is
creating
kind of yeah so so you might in general
have something perhaps analogous
something that would happen with data
containers where you can declare
some particular additional functions and
rob might have done that with a round
that will work on a certain kind of
um
compiled expression is that right
just like there are generic ones that
will work and do you have a mechanism
now for
for how to
specify those additional functions or
not
well it's function declaration so i mean
so once you once you have this type you
can just write a function declaration
that takes that type
this part
it creates it creates a type called
undirected edge and you can write any in
any compiled code that works in the type
undirected edge yup i get it i get it
okay very nice
okay right um
okay so this is essentially saying
how is undirected edge going to be laid
out in memory
how is this thing that at top level is
called undirected edge going to be laid
out in compiled code in memory and the
thing that you can put on the right hand
side there is
so integer 64-64 is a shorthand
for
a type product is that correct
yeah i mean this would this always makes
okay this pretty much always makes the
type product um so right i mean in this
case it's in the future i think there
might be some interesting things about
representing you know type sums and
stuff like that but right now there
isn't the back end infrastructure for
supporting that right um
but yeah
um so i mean fundamentally you're
basically just specifying a set of
fields that it's going to have
right like an ordinary data structure
without a union in
nc or something yes yes yes yeah
okay terrific so those things that
could be for example um uh packed arrays
of integer 64. there's no problem with
that exactly it's going to be an
arbitrary length it doesn't care about
it's not saying yes this has got to be a
fixed length record or anything it deals
with yeah
yeah yeah and also you know again they
can be polymorphic so i can have you
know undirected edges of any objects or
where i could have undirected edges of
packed arrays of any objects or whatever
you want yeah
the fact that you've named that right
hand side undirected edge why did you
put with the string why is that okay so
so basically this is if we're getting
into the the full syntax here oh i
should have included the um the
draft usage lines but but okay so so
basically um
uh the first argument is basically the
what is the head of the symbol that you
know what is the head of the expression
that we're kind of trying to make a
compiled version of
um optionally and what this does is it
will create a type with the name quotes
undirected edge because all types of
strings for their names
um
and so you can optionally give it a
different name i could call it food i
wouldn't really want to but i could
um but basically in the in the
polymorphic case you you kind of have to
give it a name like this because you
need to be able to sort of give it this
uh you know in the same ways up here you
basically said that the type is foo of t
where t is anything here the type is
undirected edge of t where t is anything
but
that right hand side more gen i mean
more fully as it was above would be type
specifier of undirected edge yes and
that works also yes
so okay so this means the undirected
edge
is really a type specifier
okay i think i get it makes sense it
means that if you want to represent an
undirected edge this is the this is the
type this is the name of the type that
you're going to have and this is the
fields that that that that type is going
to have right or basically these are the
types of the arguments i'd see i see so
if you were declaring i see so in the
end
i get it i get it this is very nice okay
so basically the top level name
is
whatever the top level name is and then
then
the default internal name is just the
stringified version of that name and
that is the thing that you would use in
a typed when you say type correct
correct you've got it right yes yes yes
we have to think about context there
christopher we've we've talked about
that but um yes yes yes
i mean so i mean there was talk about
one of the things i think is worth
thinking about at some point is about
having instead of having types all be
strings having to be symbols or maybe
these making it possible to read symbols
because then you can have contexts and
stuff like that but
there are lots of issues because for
example you'd like the type of
undirected edge to be
you know
if it were a symbol it would have to be
on directed edge but of course
then then you know
sometimes they evaluate right so you
can't really have that okay right so
that's a but i mean one could imagine a
decorator
for yeah the context thing is tricky
okay let's keep keep moving so yeah yeah
okay so there's another usage of
compiled expression declaration which is
a little bit different which is
basically for so-called expression
backed or expression based
uh
types so the point is up here
um
up up here basically
the expression was going to be you know
you tell it a lot about the structure of
this expression and then it's going to
represent it with a struct
in this case you don't tell it as much
about the structure of the expression
and it's actually just going to
represent it with the x per struct it's
going to represent it as an expression
but with a special name so for example
this would
for for example if i had something like
list expression
um as a type or maybe i'd have something
like normal expression for you know any
expression that has arguments
um and then basically give it a function
which it will use to test you know when
you give it an expression it will use
this function to test is this really a
valid list expression or whatever you
want to call it
um
okay so in the first usage case where
you just give literals on the second
argument
that is
so you're distinguishing two cases one
case is that is a test and the other
case is that is the layout in memory so
integer 64 and 364 is layout in memory
is that is there not enough is there no
syntax ambiguity between these things
there there's no ambiguity because this
one it's a it's always a function it
might be a typed function this one it's
it's a list of it's obviously it could
just be even couldn't it it could just
be that second argument just be even q
the whole thing uh well i couldn't quite
because it actually takes two arguments
but um
but but
still
so the two arguments are um
uh
basically this is the expression where
you'd like to see if this is a valid
list expression or whatever you want
and then this is the the type so
basically this t y
that will be given something like you
know in this case it'll just be given
list expression which isn't very useful
and doesn't provide you but if it was
you might not know what the concrete
type actually being given was you see
right so so for example if i had a list
expression of ts right so basically this
represents a list of integers or a list
of real 64s or whatever
um then this function in order to test
whether this expression has a valid list
of integers it needs to know it's a list
of integers right okay the function of
two arguments but in general which is
just returning true false
which in a sense conceptually is like
your t1 element of numbers back up up up
at the top of the screen there
which is again conceptually testing a
true false thing
for that a little bit but this is this
is these t ones these are like types and
we're making expression about types this
is values but right yes these so the
types execute at compile time whereas
the values execute at runtime so that t1
element of numbers is known at compile
time a little either okay so this is a
runtime this is a runtime thing yes the
cookie cutter runtime that tries to see
whether it's working
um
the uh
okay
should we should we go on here yeah so
the next one this is the last of the new
declarations um
but this one's actually very very useful
this is called library function
declaration and basically it's for
i mean this this would like to be kind
of the the library link uh
obsolete or something i mean basically
what what this does is it it
it says uh basically you tell it here's
a library here's a function in that
library and then it gives you it it
gives you access to a function that you
can call in compiled code which we'll
call the the library so in this example
here basically i'm saying
okay in
libcrypto in openssl there's a function
called sha256 this is by the way
slightly fictional example here but but
it's
so that second argument would normally
be a file path is that correct yeah
no no no no actually get rid of the dot
so you you just have the name okay so
this thing is
yeah this is anything you'd feed defined
library correct i think that it would be
good there's sort of a thread along with
this about trying to improve find
library so that you can you know do
things like write open ssl here or or
something yeah but that's kind of a
slightly separate discussion i think
yeah but you don't want to give a path
there because it means your code is very
non-transportable you you want to okay
again i get it okay so that's that's the
thing where you're finding the library
somewhere where programs find libraries
on your computer and then we can we have
a mechanism for this called find library
no right i remember right but the reason
why it's significant that it's open ssl
and not a path is that it's going to
create you know if you compile a a
function a compiled code function that
uses this like that uses this thing
then and then you transfer that compiled
code function to someone else's computer
you know when you try and run it it's
going to look for open ssl but if you
gave it a path here it's going to fail
i get the point right so okay so the the
third argument there is some kind of
way this is the type signature c
so this is the type signature using lots
of types that are basically you know
correspond to the types in c
so those will be documented in in our
list of types like integer 64 and so on
these are additional types
that are c language types is that
correct yes yes i mean you can kind of i
mean all of them are just it's c
followed by the name of the type in c
except for array which isn't a type in c
except for array which doesn't really
have a name in c
because it's just the open closed
bracket yeah yeah or a pointer yeah
and what is c size t
it's a size two
type sizes
right
what the heck is that
it's it's usually a long it's like the
size of a yeah it's the integer type
that's that you use to specify the size
of the object right like in malloc for
example it could be in could be long
there used to be what a size of macro or
something in c that's a different name
yeah it's the type of the return type of
size of
i believe
it's
it's
size t is just a standard like size t is
just you know in any ver i think since
c89 size t is just basically like the
biggest unsigned integer thing which you
use for representing and this is our
binding to c types and we've made a
collection of these it's it's okay
that's nice this is nice okay
all right so basically you'd write this
declaration
and then in your code there's a little
bit of extra syntax but this is the
easiest way to do it in your code you
then use library function which which is
sort of being repurposed here um
and you'd say library function of and
then you give it the name of the
function you declared and then you just
you know give it some arguments and it
will
go off and call it
so you need a library function decorator
because the name of the function in the
library is a string you see they might
have underbars you need a decorator yeah
fine i'm just pointing that out so but
there's a way of turning it into a
symbol so that it's not you know so you
can write oh who can't i mean just say
you just say sha256 equals library
function of quote sha-256 and then well
maybe
yes except it might be in function you
know hold all code or something we have
a way of adding it to library function
declaration that christopher's got there
yeah i mean there's this syntax here i
honestly haven't used this syntax much
so there's some examples which which i i
probably don't have time to show but
there's some examples about using
exactly this stuff too
like i made a i made a link to like
sqlite which is like very very efficient
and and produces all these nice
you know expressions as the output or
actually i for um jose i made this um
link to this package called geos it's a
computational geometry thing which uses
this
and which is like you know it was like
an order of magnitude faster than the
library link version
um and it was pretty quick for you to
put it together i mean
it took me basically a day um but it has
you know all the functionality of
of this thing what were the platforms of
putting it together
i can i can i can i can scroll over here
for a second okay so i mean basically
um
i'd say there was still a bit of weird
compiler stuff that i had to do but but
i think you know if we go through the
entire notebook above that covers all of
the weird compiler stuff i had to do as
in you know making it not weird
um but basically uh
i mean basically the way it worked is
that
the way this geos package works is they
have a type called jio's geometry and i
wrote a big long function that just took
in expressions and would turn them into
this geometry object by calling lots of
these library functions and i had
another function that took adjust
geometry object and turned it back into
an expression
um and then once you have that then it's
just a matter of you know right so i
have this two geos that creates this
basically a data structure that
represents geometry and then you go from
js to convert back
and then in the middle you know you can
call any of these functions that so that
that output line that says type product
that is a representation of some raw
set of bytes in memory is that correct
yes this is a point direction yes yeah
this is a pointer i mean basically what
happens if you serialize it if you say
full form of that what the hell is it
you could add a full form to it but in
itself it doesn't have one so but what
if you save this notebook as you
obviously did yeah you'd be hosed you'd
have to add a performance
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
why isn't there a default full form for
just these random raw
so
let me explain the issue right
there is but it's it's unuseful right so
the the reason the point is that this is
cannot be automatically serialized you
could define a way of doing it but like
basically what this contains it contains
a pointer to a geos geometry object
right which is some object from this
library that who knows what's in it who
knows how to construct one yeah
they may not have a serialization for it
you see
right but well okay but we could
generate a serialization which contains
the statement you can't serialize this
or something i mean in other words yeah
yeah
yes yes because i think that would be
useful because people will want to save
this stuff and then they'll be confused
that doesn't work commit similar it's
similar to what we have we have some
things where you know you're not saving
you know big outputs from any solve or
something
so i'm not actually sure i'm not sure
this has an interpretation
so i think it's something like okay when
you call full form on it you know when
it's in the original kernel and stuff
like that i think it does something like
this
which is sort of like a
you know
that's not very useful yeah right not
very useful but clear that i think it
should generate messages and things and
i think look my suggestion would be if
it is going to contain pointers to
random stuff which is sessions dependent
then it should be
you should have something which is
essentially a it should generate a full
form but have poisonous pieces in the
full form
because it's the same issue as what data
set when the whole data set isn't being
stored in the notebook for example
well
it's the same kind of issue so it seems
like we should have the same kind of
solution
yes well except what's the solution with
dataset the solution is that there's
ability out of life store the whole
thing and otherwise it just doesn't work
yeah you're out of luck but it but but
the out of luckness is is handled in a
in a
in a civilized or apologetic show can be
sure yeah i mean i think it should issue
messages and stuff like that if you try
and uh you know say x equals this type
product where this is from an old
notebook and stuff like that um right
but yeah but in any case i mean it's
sort of it's fun because you know uh
this this link because for example um
right i mean you can do things like like
this is computing the intersection
between you know the polygon for europe
and the polygon for russia and it takes
it you know a tenth of a second which
in the top level if you just use the
region functions takes it like a minute
um
so
yeah i mean admittedly this is making
slightly different assumptions about
the slightly different constraints and
what sorts of polygons it has like about
self-intersection basically but but
other than that
yeah um
so that's really good right
and so the point is as an example of how
this works though so uh this is how you
would define one of these functions so
here you know if you have a function
like hausdorff distance you know this is
the c signature of that function you
know it takes two pieces of geometry
and it and then it returns an error code
and if it if it succeeded it'll populate
this pointer here with a value i mean
this is an extremely typical idiom and
so the way you write this using some
stuff that we haven't got to yet is
first you have a library function
declaration
where you give it you know the name
where to find the library and the type
signature
some of which also we need to talk about
um
and then the way you actually call it is
you you create a pointer you call the
function on its arguments you know
giving it the pointer and then here i'm
a little bit unsafe and i don't check
the error code and then you you know
extract the value from the pointer and
that's it and then this is a callable
thing
um
does it feel like
they don't fully understand but we're
probably going to get to them yeah yeah
richard has a comment here about
serialization
for richard is this a comment you think
it's worth saying something about
uh perhaps not uh at this camp
okay fine the um
all right so
let's see yeah i mean so that's that's
library function declaration i think
it's
fairly uncontroversial
that's really cool
all right so let's leave what's what's
the other thing about these library but
that they're
very fast so calling into these
functions is much faster than library
link so libraries
well library link goes to a whole
complicated state machine even for tiny
atomic functions whereas this is
you know essentially a couple of you
know processor function calls
because
this can crash though as libraries
right you know if you pass in you know
zero and cast it to one of these geos
data and there's no safety net that we
can provide in modern times i mean so
this is the same as it's been for 40
years that basically the operating
system just says
there was a segfault splat
yeah yeah it's the operating system
protects your process that protects
itself from your process so your
computer doesn't crash
i i think that there might be i've heard
that there are mechanisms for sort of
catching seg faults but they're pretty
limited
yeah so
yeah okay
wow it's amazing that something like
that has not advanced at all in so long
okay
all right okay so the next thing is
right so the the
you know in all these other you know
earlier things you know their type
signatures these are basically some some
structures that live inside of type
signatures um
so the first one
yeah so the first one is basically which
which may
may have a different name um is
basically the one that you use for
representing uh
um you know it's how you deal with
basically parametrized types or is how
you do with polymorphic functions for
example so for instance if you wanted to
declare a function that you know takes a
list of anything and returns and
anything right like first would have
that type signature then this is the
structure you use to represent the type
of that function
um
[Music]
so
or identity that takes anything and
returns the same thing
sure right so so um basically a function
type with this christopher that that
might be right right like identity or
something yeah sure so i mean you have
you never work out i'll just write it
with yeah right so the type of the
function uh you know i'll do first um so
the type of the function first would be
something like you know for any t
and i'll do it for uh let's say packed
arrays i'll say it takes a packed array
we'll just do like the easiest case here
you know basically a packed list and
then we'll you know return a t
okay i understand so this is
normally if it was a literal thing so
okay i get it this is just a
parametrized yes this is a parametrized
fight
um
yep i understand
right so i mean one of the things we
talked about before was different
possible names for this because i think
you didn't like the name type for all
its argument structure is identical to
for all um because you know it takes the
list of variables and then the uh
the
uh you know the constraints basically if
you want them and then the
the type
but um there are different options
um
so i mean things like parametrized type
which i think is
maybe a slightly more accurate for what
it is
um but a bit longer yeah it's also well
the fact that it's longer i don't think
is an issue but i mean it's also
unfortunate the argument structure is as
you say
exactly the for all
right right
i'm not sure but for all by the way just
you know for all also evaluates and does
crazy things so we can't use that either
no no i know really it really evaluates
yeah
i just think type for all is is like one
of these you know it's almost like a
slogan of some kind you know it's like
like um i don't know what you know
well it's just a it's just a bit of a
strange construction i mean it's hard
well another another name which i think
would be a little more consistent with
other things would be for all type
um because basically it's
this represents a type right what kind
of type is it it's a for all
type yeah i agree that seems more
consistent with other things for all
type
i i think that's a better i think that's
better for all type is better than type
for all
what are the names of some other
um
let's see could you remind me what are
some names for some other type related
functions type constructs well i can
tell you but type specifier which just
has type first
yeah there's also this one that's right
now internally called type literal but
should be literal type because type
literal
yeah
well this direction let's see what it is
so this was one that came a bit earlier
this is basically if you have like a
packed array
you know of integer 64 comma 2 that
expands out to this basically
um
and what is that i mean okay so i
understand that there are literals
but how should what
type theory
you should think about it as uh you know
types are like sets
and you know uh
or or maybe you could think about it
just as
you know just as this is a named type
you could also have a type that's just
named two
right i mean there's no reason why
strings are special you could have a
type that's just named two
um or you could have a type that's named
15 and it's useful to have types with
names like 2 or 15 because with type
evaluate which we'll see in a second you
can do arithmetic with them and stuff
like that
for example you know if i call first on
a packed array
the result is going to be a packed array
with rank that's one less
right so you need to be able to do
arithmetic on this object here
but many types like integer quotes
integer 64. you certainly can't do a
written check correct yes correct that's
because it doesn't know the whole point
is that this is
this is like
this is not
so
right
the type
basically this is a number it knows at
compile time this is a number it does
not know a compile time that's one way
you can think about it is it always a
number that it's dealing with in literal
time it could be strings as well so we
support in principle it could be any
other things as well but we support
strings and
integers but so the basic point is that
the thing that's inside there type
evaluate
will pick it up and do something with it
right so you could sure have it two
versions of a function so you overload
functions and then you can distinguish
between the function based upon the type
and giving it a string name or a
an integer name to distinguish is is
pretty useful actually
and you can pass these things around as
terms in programs for example okay but
the thing that causes something to be
done on them is type evaluate is that
correct
not not entirely right otherwise are
they just inert packages i mean
packages right but you can you can write
you can overload functions based upon
you know function can have an argument
which takes a literal type and then
right as a pattern type thing but i mean
it could be because something like taken
away
yeah
it can take an elephant there it doesn't
matter what it is it's just a thing that
is a literal expression match
to what you told it yes right basically
i mean
in fact it's restricted but yeah in
principle it conceptually could be
anything okay but so the only case in
which it's not anything is when you use
type evaluate and where you essentially
strip the literal type wrapper and look
at the expressions inside and do
operations on them correct yes yes yes
yes
okay right so really the only reason why
there has to be
well
the main reason why there has to be a
literal type
head that you see in the top level is
because in the string case it's
ambiguous yeah like if i write a string
you know
hello how do you know that that's a type
of type literal hello in in compiled
code not in a type signature in compiled
code it's also useful to use this and
then you absolutely need it to say this
is a type not a you know not not not an
integer all right
that's the other main reason what the
right name is um
it's a little weird that
it's almost like it's a type constant or
something
is that a correct statement
but it's a you know it's a
i mean all of the types are kind of like
integer 64 is also kind of a type
constant
you know
right so i think
this is a type that
that whose name is sort of like defined
by
some literal value
what about the what about the wrapper
being called type parameter
well that would be very confusing if
there's also well yeah i don't like that
because because
up above we have things where when when
they're parametrized types those take
parameters
but there are other parameters that are
not
which are not wrapped yeah right
yeah yeah i get it
yeah okay also literal type but by the
way just for reference i think like for
example in julia i'm pretty sure they're
called they have something like this and
it's called literal types yeah i'm
pretty sure so i mean there's a
precedent script has something pretty
similar actually so
okay let's see type evaluate
yeah okay so type
evaluate
oops why is this not
there we go okay
um yeah so type evaluate i mean here's
sort of uh
basically it's it's you'd use it inside
of a type signature and you'd write
something like like this to say so that
that evaluates at the at
compile time yes yes yes
as soon as the it knows what concrete
type it's testing like if you know rank
is 23 then then it will evaluate that
i would have thought that this name
should be more like type evaluation than
type evaluate because usually
uh
you know evaluate as they do it now type
function
just a small point
in other words i mean what what do we
call uh i mean the asian ending
i'm trying to think one of the things we
have for that i mean
something like feature extraction or
something like that yeah
i mean those
those are things that usually are a
thing
i mean
i just think type evaluate just sounds
like it's going to happen now
um
anyway my suggestion would be type
evaluation
although
that isn't quite right either but you
see my point about that you see
it looks like it's going to evaluate now
um yeah maybe yeah i mean i think i i
think that this does though i mean there
is a sense in which type evaluate is
like a compared to these other type
objects that are all kind of inert this
is like a much more active object
so i don't think it makes sense that it
looks no i agree it
okay okay a small comment i'm not sure
what's right okay let's keep going
because we've got yeah okay
well okay there's a bunch of stuff i
mean i doubt we're gonna get through
everything here but but um okay so this
is the first so in terms of compiler
language stuff
um i mean this is sort of a mix of you
know kind of semantics things and just
like
the stuff at the top here how much has
this allowed us like like that sample
code that i sent through yesterday
would
i didn't quite understand i mean is the
is the end result that you can compile
that or not
so the code that you sent yesterday the
only reason it couldn't compile is
because
there were functions that it just the
compiler doesn't know about that it
should know about but doesn't know about
i mean things like complement and
intersection and stuff like that
so if you know the real solution there
is just that there should be definitions
of those um
you know the the sort of patchwork
solution is
if you wanted to write definitions of
those which so the patrick solution of
basically you could write your own
definitions of those you basically can
already do that i mean the thing i sent
you only used top level constructs but
if you wanted to write your own
definition of complement that was like a
good definition that was actually
general and worked on more than just you
know
packed arrays of rank one and stuff like
that then you need to be able to use
stuff like type evaluate type for all
you know etc
um but so the basic point is in terms of
making the compiler work in the wild
i mean
are we ready to get
people to actually go through and try
and take lots of our internal functions
write the type declarations for them
and either feed into an existing
internal code
presumably we can treat the library link
system that your
your
library function code and we can operate
on the kernel that way using that is
that correct if we expose the kernel as
a library
we we yes actually
we do
well well partly i mean there's a
there's a there's the stuff that chris
cooley is working on which might make it
possible to to use like library function
declaration to access a bunch of you
know the the i functions and stuff like
that but christopher we already this is
how we link to stuff this is how like
say you know value kernel function is
just a bunch of linkage links to the
sure sure but isn't it there's library
decoration because that didn't exist but
uh
there's a list there's a list somewhere
functions that are getting basically
exported for the purposes of the
compiler right right but they have to be
exported explicitly from the i say okay
so wait a minute so so we need a
curation effort going through the c code
and figuring out what function hooks to
export
is that true
and then we need the other end of that
which is writing library function
declaration yeah no no no no no no so
are we ready i mean i think there's
there's well i think that depends on the
i think okay to answer your question are
we ready for that i think probably yes i
think the stuff about using eye
functions and stuff like that
i think
i'm not sure
okay that's i think more useful in some
cases than others and i'm not sure like
i'm not sure i've seen a case where it's
really that useful because okay so one
case is a function like intersection
where basically
the the fundamental implementation of
intersection is actually not very
complicated i mean it's like
it's it's a it's a you know there's some
algorithm but it's like someone could
write that from scratch it's not really
useful to call the i code because it'll
also
there will be overhead with calling the
i code right
um
there's another category though which is
where the i code is actually pretty
useful which is something like i'm
dealing with a graph you know the you
know the graph raw expert and i want to
be able to do all these low-level things
on it um
in cases like that though
i think
right i mean i think in the near term in
cases like that it's fine to just call
the evaluator because if you're doing
some big thing with graphs
you know it's sort of like
the evaluator or the o function
um
and why go through the evaluator if you
don't need to that might be top level
code but uh you could extract the
pointer from the o from the symbol
that's the o function call it directly
of course
um right but i i mean what i'm imagining
is that we have a wrapper that is the
compiler hook for every built-in
function
which contains both the type signature
and the calling mechanism which might be
a library function declaration
calling into o code or i code
and it might be or it might be calling
the top level piece of top level code
which itself hopefully will be compiled
is that a fair assessment yeah sure sure
sorry go ahead
yeah in many cases the oak functions are
not ready for something that has not
been
explicitly evaluated
i see
okay
but so
all right but but i mean with a certain
type signature they would be ready
from the type signature you could deduce
if they if the stuff that's going in is
ready
yeah i think you know
pretty much inspection
yes
right but so so the thing i'm looking at
i mean you know as a practical matter
like the code that i sent through
yesterday whenever it was
that uh should be
um
right i mean i think i think basically
the effort of making it so that more
functions are compilable
i think again there are three classes of
functions they're the functions like
intersection that are simple enough that
they should just be written from scratch
in the compiler because it'll be you
know five lines
um
there are the functions that you know
they're the functions that should
definitely not be written from scratch
where i think maybe there is value
where where you could just call like if
you're calling find shortest tour or
something some big heavy function
where i think it would be okay to just
call the evaluator
and then there are functions that are
kind of
uh
you know kind of in the middle like
vertex list where it might be useful to
be able to call an i function right but
you're saying for the time being just
calling in to the top the the through
the evaluator is fine but we still need
type declarations don't wait for all
these functions yes that's that's the
harder thing to make sensible type
declaration right but remember it's not
going to be perfect we're going to have
a best guess type declaration maybe it's
a union
uh or type sum or whatever you're
calling it what are you calling type
summer cam union
okay i think i think union is a better
name if right yeah
i mean except we already have a thing
called union but anyway never mind um
we also have a thing called product
anything called for all anything called
evaluate
yes right
right okay but i mean so so fine but but
the basic point is i mean do you yet
have somebody set up to start going
through and annotating system functions
with their proposed you know preferred
type declarations
has that happened yet
answers no okay i think it should happen
shouldn't it aren't you ready to have it
happen now
i mean probably i mean i think that the
main thing is just that there's a i
think i think yes ultimately yes i mean
the main thing is i think there will be
a fair amount of decisions about
you know excited this example of of
making uh you know trying to to
basically do this process for a bunch of
graph functions
and there are a lot of decisions around
things like okay what should the type of
a graph be because a graph is of course
it's it's a polymorphic type right i
mean it can you know it's polymorphic
what what type of my vertices am i
directed or not because i have to know
whether or not when you call edge list
whether i return undirected edges
directed edges some mixed list you know
etc um so so there's there's a bit of
you know there's some slightly
complicated stuff
in designing those things but i think
especially once there's some domain like
graphs have been kind of like
designed and sketched out like once you
know what the type signature of a graph
object is then i think filling in all
the functions is is pretty simple so
this is wonderful that we're at this
point i've been waiting for this for
years
so you know we need to get appropriate
people mobilized to go and start doing
these
and they have to be people who
understand these functions pretty well
so we should break downs the project
management thing we should break down
pieces of the system
into different categories and we should
then
basically i think this group
and possibly an expanded version of this
group should work with people who know
these specific functions and try and get
the declarations created
that seems sensible
i mean i would say that that the
declarations for the things like the
core language list manipulation
functions
that's reasonably straightforward and
probably is for this group itself
and they're things which are more
applications oriented like some of the
math kinds of things that will require
participation from those people is that
fail
yeah sure
okay so we should make that happen all
right let's go and see the compiler
language stuff this is great so i mean
basically what you're saying is but for
a few names and so on you are ready with
this type declaration language
yeah but i think that i think that
basically the stuff that we've covered
up above once that's in you know
you know
you that's all that you need to be able
to just do are pretty much arbitrarily
complicated stuff with the type system
okay so fine so that will be in the is
it in the thirteen one builds
uh yes and but it's not system not not
all of it's in there and it's not all in
system context but but it's figured out
how to implement it right so there are a
few naming questions which still need a
bit of grinding but yeah you know those
can always be changed later but i
strongly think it's time to start people
working on this you know so we can put
these things in system context write
write function pages and steam ahead i
think so i mean let's do one more
discussion
you know now that we've kind of gotten
used to these functions let's do one
more discussion trying to grind the
names and see whether there's any
different naming we can come up with
um i think it would also be useful to
actually get a bunch of examples like
pages and pages of examples of what
people have actually done to try and
write declarations for system functions
because i think then it may be much
easier to see when we see these things
in combination may be much easier to see
what reasonable naming conventions would
be
and whether things which are glaringly
blah tight versus type blah look really
horrifying when you see them in
combination
sure yeah i mean i have some examples
like that i can't i shouldn't pull it up
right now but i have some examples like
that for doing the graph functions i
think i think going back to the graph
functions with the compiled expression
would be that that would be pretty
useful actually yeah yeah um
but yeah
all right well i guess um
[Music]
should we move on to the compiled
language let's let's move on to compile
language
all right so this is this is a you know
this is more of a hodgepodge of stuff so
i mean so one of the things a lot of
these are just like functions you know
because there's this relatively small
set of functions that need to sort of
their compiler specific functions
um but i mean this is sort of the first
one it's you know self-explanatory do
you have an object and you'd like to
change the type of it
because some of the time right right
right some of the third thing is the
method of conversion
yes so so let me let me there's a two
points so the first point is that
sometimes the cast
the sort of evaluator equivalent of a
cast is a no op so for example oh i'm
converting between a packed array in the
list that's a no-op in the evaluator
right
there or it looks like a no-hop um
but then there are other cases that are
not as no op-e that currently casts
real-time
real integer or or even things like uh
list to linked list the linked list data
structure right those are not no ops
yeah so there's sort of a mix here
um
but but right i mean so so those are
this uh conversion cast the other main
one is
basically bitcast which is a little bit
like the sea casting functions it's like
the low level dangerous
you know
you know
yeah the low level
things
as you can see it merges reinterpret and
bit cast if you cast from an into a
double a float in c
you you get a reinterpret cast but if
you cast from a void star to a double
star you get a bit cast so they're
not the same things
sure is this name right or should it be
type convert or something
well it's converting the thing to a
different to an uh
converting it to a thing of a different
type what will it do from real to
integer
um
it'll produce a
you know an integer that
corresponds if it exists if the
you know it it'll it'll produce an
integer that's called i think it calls
it calls like rounder floor or something
right it does kind of like similar to
what happens in c right
but the bit cost of
of that would be something much more
bizarre yeah absolutely bitcast it's
though you wrote it to memory
rename the memory to have a different
type and then read it back you see right
you would expose the bit patterns
and when you interpret cast
it it sort of tweaks you know it knows
the bit layout of integers and the bit
layout of reels
and it sort of tweaks them so it
you know bit cast is zero
you know effort there's zero run time
cost really but it may produce complete
garbage but it may produce complete
garbage absolutely right correct right
now i i would kind of argue maybe that
this is a different discussion i don't i
i'm not qualified to talk about but i
would argue reinterpret cash should be
called something else because my
pressure is that it's called reinterpret
cast because there's an lvm intrinsic
called basically reinterpret which is
what it is
calls it that but but it could be a
different name it's really between
numbers between atomic numbers so
yeah and it's really for for converting
what like sort of more general number
types to less general like you know
float 64 to float 32 kind of thing it
can go in either direction there's a
there's a definition maybe it could be a
number number
numeric or something
cast with it
well that third argument is just
numerical okay yeah right well in any
case though i mean i think
right i mean re-interpret numbers
right well in a sense the first one is
bits rather than bitcast i mean right so
this is one of the other questions is it
could just be called bit conversion and
reinterpret
but it's a little bit weird
yeah i mean it could be raw but then
yeah sure a little bit raw bits will be
fairly clear what it is let me let me
write these alternatives um
copy those all down christopher let's
have a look at them
for some reason my computer is running
at like
two frames a second yeah
i'm waiting for it to paste
this is the
linux wow
yeah yeah no i mean it's just because
i'm sharing on zoom for some reason well
maybe zoom is not properly supported on
linux
who knows
um oh wait
there we go okay
this could be you know
[Music]
raw bits
this would be
convert
and this would be
i'm going to interpret i would say
but some of these other ones also can do
like convert i think can also do some
numeric stuff but i don't know
which numeric stuff
it does different numeric stuff convert
can also fail as well and the others
like it can throw an exception
i think we need more precise definition
of what these things are yeah
okay but that function seems
uncontroversial
three arguments
right but it will evaluate so you mean
in the evaluator or i mean yes right so
that that's one of the right now it does
not
um
maybe it could but but the thing i'm the
thing i was saying though about the fact
that sometimes it's an office sometimes
it isn't is
making an evaluator version of this is
fairly non-trivial i mean especially for
like the reinterpret cast cases
i'm not even sure if it's meaningful to
to have an evaluator version of that
um
so if the compiler doesn't just run it
through compiled code
uh whatever the compiler does this yeah
go ahead well sure but but there's a
there's a certain like i'm not i
wouldn't recommend that because it's
sort of like
you know the outer product of all of the
like
well maybe you could do that i mean
there's a question of how many different
well okay no no sorry i'll give you an
example where it's hard let's say i have
um
right
it's like you have to look at every
definition every type of cast you can do
which there may be many of like a
thousand or something um and then
because fundamentally it's like an outer
product but it might be not fully dense
and then you know and then you also have
to add on top of that well what if i
have a polymorphic type what if i have a
list
right and now if i cast you know if i
have a polymorphic definition of cast
which is i can cast a list of t's to a
list of s's if there's a cast from t's
to essence
then you've just multiplied your whole
you know set of casts by two and so on
but basically the problem is that if you
want to compile
like a
polymorphic function you you know
the way you have to compile all the
different versions of it and there might
be like millions of these well i mean
look you could do a hack which is that
you could compile at runtime
one of these costs and then you could
store the
the compiled version for that particular
type signature
maybe and that might not be totally
crazy because at least i mean if you're
just casting between numbers and stuff
like that usually those things compile
like fast like you know half a second or
something but but if you did try and
compile like uh you know oh i'm gonna
cast to a linked list that will take 20
seconds or something
um
so
yeah i mean another thing by the way
another difficulty is the fact that
right this is actually the more
fundamental difficulty is that in the
evaluator you don't know what the type
of
object of obj is
right so you don't know am i casting
this from a packed array or am i casting
this from a list or am i casting it you
know
or whatever and it might be a type
that's that's quite you might there
might not even be a nice way of
representing it in the type system or
there might be many ways of representing
it the type system all right fine so so
you're basically saying for the time
being we understand what cost is if it
doesn't evaluate in the evaluator yeah i
think that's and maybe there's special
cases that could evaluate and maybe we
don't have to worry about it for right
now
yeah yeah i think so i mean i think if
nothing else maybe what we could do is
is for the no op cases
do them you know just have them be no
ops maybe in some cases like passing
from integer to real i can call n and
then in any other case i think it should
it should maybe evaluate to like a
failure and a message stuff like that
but it's pretty convenient for code
composition code construction that it's
inert and it doesn't evaluate i was
going to say the same thing
on the other hand for debugging it's a
big pain in the neck that it doesn't
evaluate
well although if you're debugging it by
running an evaluated code i think
they're probably out of that's pretty
dangerous but
also i would i would push back a little
bit about the the the code construction
stuff though because it's sort of like
you know
the only
most of the time the only reason you can
do sort of symbolic code construction
you know
you know without without having to worry
about things evaluating stuff like that
is because you know you're using so many
constructs that are these alien compiler
only constructs
but if you're you know if your program
is using lots of evaluator constructs
then you know you're going to be right
we need a separate project doing matter
programming
the other problem with having it
evaluated is it probably will work in a
different way from in compiled code when
evaluated and compiled code can work in
the same way that's that's super useful
but
this this might
use that differently all right okay well
fine i don't think this is the most
important point yeah absolutely right
right okay but i think the trivial cases
should work just so that it's demorable
what the hell it does
yes i agree
um okay
all right all right
next
the next ones is there's a little pair
of two pointer front pointer
um
so
actually let me show these are the usage
lines
these are the draft usage lines first
um
and then i have sort of c analogs of
them up there
but but basically
uh
these handle the cases of i want to
create a pointer you know basically i
want to create like an integer on the
stack
that uh you know i can call some library
function and that function could
populate that as i showed you the house
dwarf distance example before
um
there's some things about populating
pointers that you're given and stuff
like that all this is really only for
dealing with external programs you
should never write this for anything
else
um
but wait a minute the pointer object
thing is going to be something which is
unsavable unserialized correct yeah it's
not gonna right i mean i think that
there is there's uh
yeah it's not can you ask about one
weird case which is shared memory
parallel computation is that a crazy
case
in which you want to send the pointer
between processors or is that just
completely bond as long as that stack
frame is alive the pointer is alive um
so
right but i don't know whether that's i
don't know whether we have any mechanism
for that
my guess is that that if you want to do
that you you'd have to use heap
allocations anyway
which
i think the current actually there's
some stuff lower down that's sort of
tentative and new
um about dealing with heat memory but i
think that the general
the general concept here is that if you
want to allocate something on the heap
you should just call malloc which there
will be
some you know a mechanism for but it
won't be beautiful but it's basically
like we don't want to encourage people
we don't want to provide some mechanism
for people to basically do low-level
pointer management that's sort of very
dangerous um
and doesn't get reference counted and
doesn't get referenced exactly
okay so the pointer object is just
something with a nice exotic it can have
some some really exotic icon on it that
suggests it's an alien thing
so you mean if it gets if it's return i
mean it doesn't even have to be
returnable to an expression like we
could make it just like if you try and
return a pointer object
you know to an expression it'll just
tell you i can't convert that to an
expression yeah or it could you know
give it a thing oh i think it should you
say here creates a new pointer object
so why not
okay so i i would argue that
if you return
level it'll do nothing on the top level
right now i would argue i i thought
about this a little bit i think it
should probably
intentionally fail the top level most of
the time because it's like we really
really do not want to introduce fun you
know that then it's usage line shouldn't
be what it is right now i mean it should
say something like
creates a new
internal you know represents the
creation of a new internal pointer
object
or maybe you could say the current code
in the current function frame perhaps
something yeah it should mention that it
only really exists in compiled code
right right right i mean that just seems
like it's it's a thing which you could
just do with wild abandon whenever you
feel like but do we like the shame
the name two-pointer from pointer
it's pretty nice i think sorry so
two-pointer is a little bit of a pun
also because it has sort of so okay
these are the usages with their c
analogs below them which i think is more
understandable so basically two-pointer
is
um
actually it's a little bit different
it's actually two pointer is is is this
um
it's basically saying allocate this
thing on the stack and then give me a
pointer to it you need the address
why just you need to know how big it is
no so the point is is that it
well by by default basically it can use
you know through the type inferencing it
will know what type it needs to have so
for example
right this is so for example if i if i
pass if i create a pointer with you know
two pointer open close actually come on
i can just show you there's an example
you've got an example there christopher
example
right right here so
right so the point is here the the
argument the third argument of house
dwarf distance is a right now it's
called handle iron it should be pointer
is a pointer to a c double
um
and so you see that if we look here i
passed in this variable out and i
created that with true pointer but it
can the type inferencer knows
because it knows you know what this
function takes it knows that okay that's
that's a pointer to a c double
um
and if it can't tell if there's a reason
you can't figure it out then you can use
typed around it which is basically the
way of you know annotating it and saying
i know you can't figure out the type but
but you you are a handful right you know
but
you hopefully don't need that right
yeah hopefully you don't need that
okay
i'm thinking let me just understand this
for a second so two-pointer
creates
just a memory
address
allocating memory on the stack or what
almost
on the stack yeah
so it's like when this code is running
it will allocate that memory
and it knows how much memory to allocate
because the type of out is something no
how does it know yes
yes because because it's because you're
not it
right because basically
let me actually go down to this example
here it knows from type inferencing that
the type of this you know object here
pointer to a double right okay and it
knows how big a double is so
yeah
okay i mean the thing that's confusing
to me
is that i would expect that two-pointer
a thing with that name would take an
expression and return to me like an
ampersand thing of that expression
in some sense
right the problem is is that that's
yes there's a version of it that's a
little bit like that but it's subtly
different okay and it's because
basically the ampersand operator in c
is a
does not make sense in the compiler like
it is a the ampersand operator in c sort
of relies on the the semantics of c in
the way that c represents variables to
work and in the compiler
you know
you can't just if you have some object
it doesn't necessarily make sense to ask
you know what's your memory address
um
so so basically the this function which
is the one that's kind of like the
ampersand operator this actually
this actually
kind of makes a copy
like what it does is it um
uh actually i think i've written this
example i think this this code might be
slightly wrong
the the point is is that basically if
you if you say you know two pointer of v
you know x equals two pointer v and then
you modify
you know x in some way you you you put
something into x that won't modify v
right that won't make some mutable thing
which is what the ampersand operator in
c does
so in other words if it was called
address of then that's what you would
expect to have happen that if you change
x
no
yeah yeah if you said address of and
then you got this pointer back and then
you told x you know you use this usage
to basically change the value that x
points to
in c that would modify v
but here it would not because this is a
kind of a copy
yep
okay i think i need one more iteration
of this but maybe not right now let's
let's just keep going for a couple
minutes here um
so
i understand okay that that i mean
again
we should probably grind one more time
on some of these names but that seems
like a good start here
yeah there's also some things about the
names of what the pointer type is called
but i think it should be pointer
i i think it should be pointed too yeah
now we could make a very long point of
reference but that's not particularly
why why do that that's very redundant
yeah it is total yeah
okay
okay let's just see all right
of the other things how much more is it
yeah
well i mean there's a there's
some more especially some long ones that
i again i don't think we're gonna get
through everything i think
let's go just give us a little bit of a
preview
okay okay well so i'll preview all of
them or preview one of them first no
preview of all of them i mean just
so so rough preview is
um this one is about
um basically functions that take types
so there's a whole class of these
functions that basically do things like
given a list you want to ask it what is
the type of you know of your of your
elements or given the graph what is the
type of your vertices and so this is a
proposed
you know
hijacking of information to uh to let
you do that
um
then there's a type of this is kind of a
cool one especially because it has good
behavior in the top level this is
basically
compiles a program and tells you what
the type of its output is without
running it so for instance you know here
you know i'm running this and i think
this this will yeah this will just work
and it runs pretty quickly you know it
takes like a tenth of a second because
it only composite up to the type
inference and phase and the critical
thing is you know
that echo is not echoed but yet it knows
what it's going to return no side
effects all right
right and and the
the
right and this is super useful inside of
compiled code because yeah for doing
tight manipulation stuff that's super
easy it's useful in top level i think
it's quite interesting in top level as
well actually well it's probably a good
way to generate if you're trying to
figure out what on earth is the type
specification for some
random list somewhere i mean
just type type specifier of like the
list one two three
yeah so i mean this will uh i mean of
course this is
yeah yeah this is restricted to what you
can compile so okay but just the list
one two three but yeah that should work
packed array yeah
see look at that that's really useful
because i don't want to type all that
junk in
i should be able to say you know end of
that and it'll tell me it's it's a real
64 and stuff
okay so just just give me for a second
just just make it just make the thing
instead of the end there just make that
a list of pairs for example
like
yeah you want to be rank
yeah rank two but now my question here
is how does it know that this is
supposed to be a thing of arbitrary
length
because packed arrays are arbitrary
length
it's true that there's i mean this is a
thing that needs to improve in the
compiler anyway that there are a few
different types of lists there's packed
arrays for like arrays and matrices and
linear algebra there's list vectors
which is for if you wanted you know have
a list of dates or something that's for
basically representing lists not packed
arrays
then there's also a thing called that's
right now called list tuple but maybe
that's an okay name actually but
basically it's for representing uh lists
that have different types of different
slots
you know short lists yeah um
and right now those don't get
automatically made right so you know
this won't compile right now it should
compile but but but um
yeah right so it's okay so when you're
generating the type of in that line
above there you are making
the
minimal maximal
type
that is
it is that is a type which i mean that
thing could be
a list of three elements each of which
is two elements long specifically but
you are assuming that it generalizes
to be
a list of arbitrary length in
an arbitrary length list of arbitrary
length lists
correct
but with instant 64s as that i mean yes
and no i think i think that that would
be a that would probably be a good
principle
that might be a good principle for
deciding these right now it's pretty
arbitrary i mean because i think the
basic history is that it used to be that
this thing just only worked with
factories it always did pact arrays now
can do some slightly different things
um but yeah i mean there probably should
be a principle like that for deciding
how it picks um there might be some
instances though where you might want to
pick a more a less restrictive type but
you know for example if we had a type we
might have some very specialized types
that you don't necessarily probably typo
is going to get a second argument which
is going to be all kinds of information
about what well there is an example well
you could put typed around things
yeah i mean so you can of course yeah
right you can also tell it for instance
um
right you could write ty i mean then
it's not type of isn't very useful but
yeah you can tell it typed and then
specify what the type these is but i
should mention i mean type of also has a
second argument
um where you can basically tell it about
you know variables assume that x is a is
a real 64 or assume x is because you
know i might not have a real 64 on hand
but i wanna i mean this is really for
something like assume x is a geos
geometry object
right yeah
um
yep but yeah okay so i mean we're just
skimming these so um
the next is uh
right so so
this we already talked about basically
if you do a library function declaration
you can then call it using library
function the other one is um
the entire c standard library
um so the idea is that you can just call
the c standard library by using library
function spectacular um
right how many another alternative how
many more libraries should we do this
for
lots um
lots
well i mean in general lots of uh yeah i
mean in general lots but i mean i think
that the c standard library is one
that's always
you know it's always linked basically so
we might as well do it not not all not
in webassembly so
not always okay
but shouldn't this have a name that says
what library it is before you give this
book okay so that goes into the
declaration so the library function
declaration should have that right but i
mean as a generic thing it's just like
look this is very much like deep calling
the paclet symbol deep call thing for
paclets
see what i'm saying this is like a deep
call into this library okay so i think
the thing is is that all right those are
two points i mean first of all is that
there's the case where you use library
function declaration where you have to
specify the location of the library and
stuff like that but the point is that
this is a library function that just
comes it's always there you don't need
to declare it i know it's an
ever-present one and and so then one
alternate one idea was to use things
like external evaluate and you know you
can even do external evaluato it's from
c and stuff like that the reason why we
don't do that is because these names are
all super global because of the way that
that linking works
um and so
right i mean there's no there is no knit
there are no name spaces there is no
where what library does this come from
it's just names
it's actually been linked it's been
linked that's your point yeah yeah
accessible this way it actually has to
have been linked into the process yep
yeah
right
so i mean so so you might as well i mean
we could have you write you know other
things in here but but you might as well
just write the name what's the point the
only identifier but the question is if
we're going to provide a set of
standardly linked things we probably
need to curate their names
yes definitely i mean so i think the
csun libraries the c types right the c
types
that we've we've done some
curation
another one that's possible is the lvm
intrinsics
um
but i'm not i don't really know enough
about those to know how much sense that
makes
um
otherwise
yeah yeah richard's commenting about
auto parsing of headers which we have
done some work on yeah yeah yeah
this was the original you know i really
like to say when i when i first got you
know my first the first time i ever used
the compiler for anything like
four year three or four years ago
um it was because i wanted to do exactly
this
um of parsing c header files because we
have clang link which can parse header
files and give you the ast and stuff
like that
so i think this is this is a definite
target would be to you know parse a
header file generate a big list of
library function declarations which by
the way has to make some decisions about
things like oh this takes a char star is
that a list is that a byte array is that
a string is that a c array of
small numbers you know whatever but it
could automatically generate a big
library function list of library
function declarations and then you know
and then you can just call those using
library functions but
right yeah all right quick quick quick
look through some of these other things
yeah yeah so some of these other ones
these ones we have to be really quick
because these ones are the complicated
ones so all right so this one is about
how there are some bits of functionality
um that that it might be nice to
you know
let users modify yeah basically if you
want to create a hook so something like
oh i have this jio's geometry object and
there's a function that needs to get
called when the ref count goes to zero
like in order to free the geos thing you
know how do i do that i declare
dysfunction or whatever so that that's
the hands of that various kinds yep
right
another one is um this is a mega
complicated one that we really can't get
into about expressions basically right
now the expression type in the compiler
is the this the you know is the kernel
expert struct um but because it's in the
compiler you know its evaluation
semantics are completely different as in
it doesn't develop it's like mc code
basically
right so i mean if i call the point is
if i call reverse on an expression the
evaluator i get this if i recall reverse
on this expression in compiler you would
imagine that you get back this
expression right
um
you know unevaluated so so basically the
point is this is super useful for
writing efficient code um
but it's also completely different from
the evaluator well it is the meta case
of the evaluator it's the it's the
pre-evaluator of some kind it's the
thing that we have often wanted which is
the thing that handles unevaluated you
know it handles an expression without
evaluation
yeah
sure yeah i mean
the basic issue though is that if we
want a definition of reverse that runs
on expressions in order for it to be
consistent with the evaluator it needs
to return this
right
yeah christopher it would be the one
plus one that that would evolve it would
be the when you constructed the one plus
one that you would change
that's when that would maybe so
yeah
unless but you know we
yeah i mean not maybe somebody
especially
there might be ways of doing i mean i
think there's things with unevaluated
where it might be subtly right right or
you have
a com you know list a comma b and then
you do a equals three
you know then you're sure
now you ask for a yeah so i mean i think
the point is reverse does need to
you know
yeah so so basically the the issue is
there are a couple different options
here um one of the options is to have
two expression types one that is
basically
one called expression which behaves like
the evaluator one with a different name
that's basically the raw expert type
that you know doesn't evaluate unless
you ask for it and stuff like that
um but yeah yeah this is a bigger issue
another issue is how you construct some
of these held expressions and stuff like
that
um
then there's uh
right then then there's an issue
yeah i mean this one kind of is a bit
important but but i think uh
it's not far enough along with the
design i think we talked too much about
it and basically this is about if you
declare for example you know type
product you know struct that you you'd
like how do you actually instantiate one
of them one option is create data
structure but there are some arguments
that
yeah i mean there's some arguments
especially for the purpose of having a
thing to send to an external program as
a raw collection of bits is that correct
that would be a very common case yeah i
mean there's some cases where you might
that might be simpler than that
um that don't involve external programs
but yeah that would be one example
um
but but but yeah so there's there's
there's that um and there's a question
about whether that's you know
how to
whether it's distinction create data
structure and if so how to name it so
it's clear what the distinction is and
stuff like that we've not thought this
through so yeah we haven't thought that
through too much then there's then
there's um
this unnamed
thing that's currently called unmanaged
which is the thing about basically how
to deal with rogue pointers and stuff
like that which is basically a way of
you know
basically uh there are certain functions
like for example we have a type for c
strings and that's very useful fc string
but then you might be able to you know
call string reverse on it or you can ask
for the string length of it or you know
you can convert it to and from a string
so it's useful to have that type um but
the issue of course is that
you know a c string
is is like this is a pointer it's this
very dangerous thing and you have to
make sure it gets free and stuff like
that so basically the argument or the
idea is that we'll have some sort of
object that's called like managed with
or block or something like that that
basically uh
basically you tell it here's this object
and then i'm going to use it and when
the block ends you're going to click
you're going to free this memory and we
can have a little bit of escape analysis
to make sure that it doesn't you know
escape the block um
but right i mean basically it's just a
way of forcing people to uh i mean
that's just go for these blocks i mean
shouldn't shouldn't you have the the
management tag be something associated
with the block so that you can nest
manage blocks
i'm not sure what you mean i mean you
could with this syntax you could nest
them i mean basically you're just saying
this is the list
how does it know that the unmanaged
should be managed by the
you know the most right the nearest and
closing managed block or the next
managed block well because basically
what you do is okay if i have some
object which has type unmanaged you know
this is the idea is that you have a c
string but if you actually want to get a
c string you're going to get it and it's
going to show up with this annoying
wrapper and all of your functions like
string reverse aren't going to work on
it because it's got this annoying
wrapper so if you want to actually use
it there's this function called manage
block and you give it basically this
thing in its first argument and what
it's going to do is it's going to
populate
this variable here with a sort of
unwrapped version of of this right it's
going to you know so that will be this
sort of dangerous object but but because
you know i i defined this this first
argument of managed block it now knows
when this managed block finishes it can
free that memory
um
i get it i get it i hadn't really read
this correctly so that thing at the
beginning is in fact precisely what i
was thinking it might be which is
right okay it's this but it's but it's
i'm not sure whether it should be set or
rule or something like that because it's
unwrapping it so it's it's not literally
going to have this value it's going to
have some unwrapped version of that
value um but yeah yeah i get it i get it
i've spread the
that's the sensible way for the manage
block roughly to work
right um and then you know as time goes
on goes on we can write you know nice
escape
escape detection stuff to to make sure
that you know the pointers aren't
you know making their way out there
this name is wrong and there are many
different options for names
um
[Music]
so yeah
um
yeah the very last thing i mean i don't
really have much written here but
basically this is this is the thing we
talked about before about having a
different syntax i mean this is this is
on the assumption that uh
having strings for heads is too ugly
which i generally think it's pretty ugly
um
but on the other hand the type
specifiers start to sort of build up
massively if you nest a bunch of these
things in you know a packed vet array
and a list vector in a hash table so
left associative so what you're saying
is you want some kind of left
associative operator form for type
specifier
is that right
well i
i'm not sure what you mean by left
associative operating i mean basically
it's just
maybe it's right to certain actually i'm
i mean this is the thing this is the
thing that you know we talked about a
while ago
but um
yeah yeah i mean the the idea is just to
have some sort of of syntax so that you
don't have a string as a head
but you know but it's still uh
something with angle brackets is
possible because that's
templates use that
yeah i mean well one option would be
something like well the issue is that uh
if you use actual you know
you can't use actual
angle bracket colon for example
like uh like this like associations but
with a colon for example i mean i'm just
throwing that out
oh that doesn't quite work
right sorry
right i mean there's many that looks
like a squiggly arrow of some kind so i
don't think that works but
um
yeah i mean so there's
there's a lot of different options it's
unclear what uh
you know okay but the basic point is
this is a thing that should represent
this is the syntax for type specifier of
packed array and then
compound compound types yes right and
then carry in that thing
um yeah yeah right
but you want it don't you to be able
don't you want it to do you want it to
another level of currying or not or is
that the only level that you need
you mean you mean do i want it to be
this
no
you're never one i don't think i don't
think so i i don't think so
okay so it's just one level
yeah and the other thing that's nice
that this could have a nice so another
advantage of having
uh basically having some nice syntax as
opposed to having strings for heads is
that that means that you know
this object will actually be a type
specifier and it might have some
prettier formatting or like synthetic
which probably should follow whatever
whatever its pretty form is should
follow
visually whatever the thing is that is
the
you know the ascii way to type it in
um sure yeah
i mean
this is the main thing but yeah yeah
i mean the problem and we need a a
um
at least we need an opener and a closer
because we can have an arbitrary number
of arguments correct
yeah
unless we have an infix form and then
those arguments are in the list
that's a little weird i think
because these things are really the type
is taking arguments right right really
like a function also
we use lists to represent function
arguments as well
that's true yeah
can i understand if if you had for
example at open bracket
as the initial thing do you need a
closer that is matching with that or can
you just determine it by by close
why am brackets
um i think you can just determine if i
close brackets
i mean because it's just that you know
you just count the number of open
brackets and you know which closed
bracket you know so your so your form
there with colon would actually work
yeah i mean i think this is this is a
participle
thing
um this might even know it's a syntax
failure right i mean colon
is massively massively complicated in
the parser
we have to think very carefully before
we commit to that
it might not be implementable
colon means a bunch of things already so
indeed it does
i don't think it means adding another
thing might be a step too far maybe it'd
be okay but
this is an implementation question
though right not not a
synthetic absolutely this seems quite
instrumental
that's more than an implementation what
about colon colon
well that means something already right
that means something different i mean
single colon means something but yeah
let's see
i would kind of question a little bit
well actually you know
in in um at least in rust colon colon
basically means the same thing yeah
that's a little bit crazy
well i don't think it's bad because i
think it look it is very exotic looking
which i think is good because we don't
want a syntax which people could type
which elementary users could type by
yeah yeah i i think the colon colon that
that probably is implementable
yeah okay well maybe that's the thing
then i mean you can see the syntax
highlighter is struggling a little bit
because it thinks it's a message name
but yeah because it doesn't matter
right
that seems like the most plausible and
it seems like it's exotic looking but
it's not you know it's exotic and alien
but it's not completely incomprehensible
yeah
right
or
angle bracket
i don't think angle bracket is the right
thing because it you know in the end
it's going to be a brackety-like kind of
operation and i think angle bracket
unless it's something like an
association type thing i just don't
doesn't sorry the thing i'd be scared of
is the closed bracket it's gonna no no
no i didn't mean that i meant angle
bracket open bracket
get rid of the double colon
like that
i think that's going to look a bit like
associations
yeah probably
i quite like the
non-symmetry the colon colon open and
close that's that's it
yes because it's basically saying
i that's my preference from from these
is the
bracket
i'll have a look at that in the position
fine
well this is wonderful was there
anything else in this notebook just just
to uh no i mean there's there there's
the geo stuff and then there's also a
sqlite thing but it's similar to the geo
stuff
this looks great so when can we really
you know
get
lots of
i mean because i just want actual code
in the wild to compile
yeah yeah i mean i think i think
i think at this point it would make
sense you know we could have people just
working on trying to just go down lists
of functions and make them compilable i
mean i think that's
fine that's plausible
so are we ready then let's
aubry can
can get
you know
going on um
on actually
uh you know following up on that
okay
um
okay
well interesting well it's very very
nice
and and this is and you say you can get
this into the system context in thirteen
one
yeah or what you've done so most of it i
mean there's there's most of the things
that we talked about and basically um
uh
all the declaration stuff pretty much
all the declaration stuff is either in
or like we'll be in in like a day two
days
um
some of this type stuff this is this is
basically in except they need to move to
system and there's some probably name
changes like for all type or literal
type
um
uh these ones are in they just need to
move to system
um and get documentation and stuff
um
you know same same with this one uh yeah
i mean it's only really the stuff about
um
[Music]
some of this stuff about basically the
stuff that we didn't get to properly
like with expressions and things like
that but those are the things that are
still a little bit
um all right so we need a follow-up
meeting yeah we need to think about the
library naming business that's that's
that's the install that might be a
different i mean that might be actually
that might be good for like an lcc
meeting or something i would argue the
thing about making find library a bit
less dumb
yes um
i mean i i looked about that a little
bit but it's actually a little bit
complicated because for example one of
the things that would be nice
is you know basically the idea is to
have
some sort of list somewhere
maybe it doesn't even have to be user
exposed but something like association
where basically you can tell it you know
oh
you know
open at the name quotes openssl that's
lib crypto and you can search for that
on the path but then the issue is that
you know the the first issue you run
into is that well open ssl is actually
two libraries it's lib ssl and lib
crypto you need both and they have
different names on windows and linux and
mac
yes they do there's only one library on
windows i believe and um but then also
that means that well if find library
returns that then load library also
needs to be able to accept a list
because find library might return one
and then you know you know more stuff to
figure out okay yeah exactly
okay um okay well this looks really good
i mean this is uh
wonderful progress i mean in but let's
okay why don't we plan a follow-up
meeting preferably within a week or so
to go through before at least i've
forgotten what all the issues were to go
through and dig into a few of these
other things that were in later parts
agenda
right yeah sounds good
okay thanks a lot thanks to folks on the
live stream too